[Music]
guys it's not like we needed anything
starting off at number 10 for us is
ruby's haunted apartment
he was streaming alone while house
hitting for a friend and took a break
from skyrim to talk to his chat
and then this happened
as well
the light in the hallway kept turning on
despite the switch for it being
in the room in which he was apparently
alone in
dude the light you just turned it off
and it went back on
then came more slamming
and some box throwing i'm like on the
low-key watching the door right now
same like how much it's not like we
needed just guys it's not like we needed
anything
roomsie eventually had enough of all of
this and decided to leave
but not before filming a quick video i
just want to let everyone know
that i'm all right i guess so
oh cool there were some doubts about the
authenticity of the haunted apartment
but almost four years later roozie still
maintains that the video is legit
i would go back one last time uh just to
have like a sort of trilogy
wrap it up you know do whatever people
say in the comments that way
i can have like a surefire without a
doubt like look guys this is
uh this is as real as it gets you know
well there you go guys
as you just saw streaming it's not
always fun and games usually
you're watching xqc freaking out about
something or
shroud hitting some insane shot but
sometimes
things can get scary and when that
happens
it can be as hilarious as it is
terrifying
buckle up then as we continue with the
top 10 creepiest stream moments
next up at number nine xqc asked a
question of the spirit realm
in phasmophobia but i don't think he
expected his girlfriend to answer
show me a sign
[Music]
is there a spear here
oh my god could you not
at the number eight spot now we have
chuckles in the park
in late 2016 there was a nightmarish
frankly horrible craze that swept the
world
creepy clowns out in the streets
youtuber rackaracka was streaming one
night while out with friends
in the hopes of running into one of
these creepy figures and as the old
saying
goes be careful what you wish for that's
cute
huh are you you're on you're on youtube
so not attacking
dude they tried to keep it cool but when
a clown runs at you
what else can you do but book it
stop my friend it doesn't matter how
fast you run though
clowns will always find a way excuse
you're live on youtube
you're live on youtube you're live on
you everything you do is on the internet
i swear to god
moving on to number seven now we have
this legendary clip where
jurassic junkie shows us why horror
games will never quite compare to the
occasional horrors of parenthood
the okay
at the number six spot now s fan is
playing things slow he's taking his
pictures
but unfortunately he made the mistake of
taking his eyes off the game for
just a moment i hate this game
moving on to number five now we have
ksi's soul leaving his body for just a
moment
he was playing some south park stick of
truth nothing too scary there
you are but then his friends decided to
pay him
an unannounced visit i don't know if
they planned out this move beforehand
but it could not have gone more
perfectly first episode is definitely
the one
with a piss out back
number four features blasphemous hd who
is no stranger to horror
while playing some five nights at
freddy's he pulled off a jump that most
pole vaulters would be envious of oh god
i don't know oh god damn it
here we go
at the number three spot a streamer by
the name of kobe makes some of
the most unholy noises i've ever heard
from someone playing
phasmaphobia kobe drop the camera bro
i'm going back in the basement dawg
bro why are you kidding me
[Music]
let me
for our number two now swag dracula
likes to use a custom donation alert
when he streams
hello
[Music]
jesus no poop for you
[ __ ] you [ __ ]
[Applause]
scream the message at the end just makes
this one i also love how
he was laughing just moments before he
got scared for a second time
[Applause]
and finally at number one in space no
one can hear you rage
tyler1 made a name for himself by
getting angry but little did fans know
he's perhaps
even more entertaining when he's scared
out of his
mind in a game like alien isolation
tyler had two enemies the xenomorph and
the slow speed of closing
doors oh [ __ ]
i gotta go guys i gotta go i gotta go i
gotta go
okay sometimes the alien didn't even
need to be there for him to be
terrorized
oh [ __ ] it didn't matter how many times
the alien got him we can just
never get enough of this
[Music]
stop spamming your radar tells you where
to go it doesn't well there you go guys
that
is that which one of those was your
favorite personally
i can't get enough of the jump scares i
could literally sit there and watch like
a 10 hour compilation of
just jump scares i love them that much
if you made it this far
into the video then please leave us a
like it does help a lot
leave us a comment to let us know what
you want to see next on the channel
subscribe if you haven't done so already
and i'll see you all in the next video
sometimes things can get scary and to be
honest i personally
say i find it as hilarious as it is
terrifying buckle up now then for the
sake and then i'm
put the last line that i had down before
course